I'm here with Dan Russell again and he
is just mentioning something that
sounded kind of cool and I wanted to see
what happens he says that I can
literally drag an image into the search
bar that's right and it will create an
image search so I have an image here
okay of me so what we're gonna do is try
to find more pictures like that of
yourself also of this picture of the
picture you've got of yourself okay
actually we can even click on that image
that's that's the image yep that's you
right that's me that is me okay
that is me all right good so does it go
here it well what you need to do is go
to Google Image Search there you go and
I just drag it drag it in only then drop
image here that's pretty Sofia uploading
file and this is exciting it's gonna run
thee oh look at that
look at that me and some Indian movie
stars best my true calling that's right
look at that that's his name is Shahrukh
Khan are you related not that I know of
not not better this his name is Salman
Khan sorry there I mean so what are the
so it does because that that file did
not have my name on it that's right but
these folks right here have a lot in
common - his name is my name that's
right I mean the images are similar
we're all wearing like black shirts or
coats we have similar complexions and
gray background mm-hmm so how did it
know so let's scroll to the very top and
I'll show you so when you dragged it in
you drag that image yeah and it tried to
figure out the best search that we
returned that image oh so you guys know
that if I right yeah because you people
all often search the other way around
that's right so you see there yeah
exactly salman khan khanacademy and then
it looked for other images that had
visual similarity and some of those try
so that's why the Khan is showing up a
lot right and that's why you get your
brother a handsome gentleman and and and
then and then obviously his name is
Salman Khan so that's right but they
also look and this who I don't know who
he is but well dark shirt on and white
and white background similar complexion
right very cool yep